so hello everybody i am here with gutier
pierrozak
gaucier is a lover of symbolism you know
very fascinating person in himself and
he went on a very a really exciting
journey to
dive into and discover the works of luis
charbonneau lasse many people don't if
you might not know about him he was an
early 20th century symbolist uh very
important influential but because of the
war and because of many things that were
happening around him some of his work
got lost
and uh some of it got forgotten there is
an english uh version of his main work
that we know about which is the bestiary
of christ a highly edited version his
french version is quite longer and more
uh is fuller
and gautier is now involved in a new
publication called the vulnerary of
christ in which
this is shabano's work on the symbolism
of the five wounds of christ and just
how universal they are and how extended
that language kind of becomes in
christianity and so it's a very it's a
very fascinating book to be published
right now a very important one and so
i'm really looking forward to diving
into his
discovery of shabano and also
and also the work itself
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
and so gautier maybe you can start off
very simply and tell us how you became
interested in the work of shabonu lasse
yes thanks for
inviting me to your to your podcast
i
i've been very interested in symbolism
and christian symbolism in particular
since i was very young
i was introduced to this through the
fact that i lived in france i lived in a
little tiny village with a church that
was
over a thousand years old and they were
symbols engraved on the outside of the
church and of course it started my
cursity and that i kept you know there's
a lot of people who were along the way
who who
advised me to read which book and that
book and um over the years i was
becoming more interested in the the
bigger
aspect of symbolism it's not just
limited to
to christianity it's just the way i'm
looking at it
it is a language based on intuition uh
you use symbolism when you cannot
express with words some concepts that
are just divine or
uh and and the best example and i'm
gonna bring that back later is the
concept of infinity our brain cannot
comprehend infinity we can get close to
it we can use with words we can try to
explain but we cannot define it i think
symbolism
um
allows you to go a step above with
communication of this concept and i'm
sure you you you understand there's
patterns surrounding us that that cannot
be explained but we can feel them
intuitively so that was my approach i
also have
kind of a
specialty
my brain sees in colors i see letters in
colors i see depth when i listen to
music so
i realized after a while it's i think
it's a known condition that i have
already in my brain a wire that bypasses
language
and so
that's why i really appreciate uh
symbolism so
in the process i was reading um
ronagno she's a a parent a parent
niallist in france
and found out
that he was involved with a christian
publication in the early mid 1920s
called regnabit
was
a periodical monthly
where it was dedicated to the sacred
heart of jesus
everything about it
from
doctrines symbol arts philosophy poetry
anything
and
within this
periodical was a gentleman named luis
charbonneau lassie that started
engraving for the periodical he was
doing the
the the wooden engravings and they would
print these symbols these
representations that's how he started
okay participating in 1921 i believe it
was
after a while he started writing
articles about uh some of his findings
so
what's very interesting is that luisa
bonolesi was born in 1871 so he's a 19th
century kind of
old-school
gentleman um
he joined early
i think he was 11 years old when he
joined a
christian school
uh he stayed there constantly and and
wanted to become a priest
and
he just became a teacher in that school
started trying to become a priest and in
1903
uh a law in france just separated
a
church from the state officially and the
the the congregation he was part of was
uh
disappeared simply disappeared so he
ended up being back in
into uh the secular life if you want
and um
at that time and it is so interesting
how little details can change some
people's lives
one of his
teachers at the congregation he was part
of
was also
an archaeologist or maybe early at that
time they were kind of digging around
and finding
stuff they didn't expect they would dig
under old stones you know standing
stones they would find
uh skeletons and a lot of old
artifacts
and he became very interested in this i
have some old writing of his where in
the early 1900s he was actually
exploring
underground caves
where people during the past wars
religious wars and they were hiding and
they would leave artifacts behind
so it's an interesting
aspect because he became an
archaeologist which is a scientist
while being truly a christian
true christian and by the way a catholic
but
uh very uh interested in
all sorts of symbolism so he
he found on his own all these artifacts
he started questioning why he was
finding uh
there was really a lot of representation
of christ through animals
through all sorts of symbols and that's
what the history of crash is really
interesting
in
so
fast forward in the 1920s he became part
of that
periodical regnabit
and he started using his finding
archaeological findings to write about
the symbolism of christian artifacts so
he would talk about the lion he would
talk about the the bull
um and he would also explore and that's
the interesting part for the vulnerary
all the symbolism of the heart of jesus
and his biggest mystery for him is how
come i'm finding artifacts that are
hundreds of years
um
they were showing the heart of jesus
even though the doctrine of the sacred
heart only appeared in the in the 17th
century so that's where his own quest
started there
and um it took us
and we'll talk about it if you want
very deep in this book yeah and so he he
was
working in collaboration even until i
guess the end of i don't know who who
passed away first but until the end of
their lives he worked in collaboration
with guinea yes uh in this kind of
rediscovery of symbolism yeah and uh and
this is what kind of led to the the
bestiary and so he really is a
i would say one of them he was one of
the key figures in the sense that there
was a lot of symbolism thinking
happening obviously at the end of the
19th and early 20th century but a lot of
it was in the in the stranger world the
world of the kind of esoteric world and
the world of
um
and all of these kinds of worlds but but
shabbat unless they really wanted to
frame his understanding of symbolism
with within his catholicism and society
yeah yeah i call that he's he was an
auto doc catholic orthodox catholic he
was very
very careful not to
to steer into occultism isotherism and
all that however him and genome became
really good friends so as i mentioned
through different people who knew each
other they were introduced
and um charbonneau
and genome met
geno went to his house in uh lewdown and
saw all his artifacts
and in fact when you what you see
through their correspondence until the
from 1924 to
[Music]
1946 when shabo no lasse died before
geno was helping shabono
by providing findings of his about
christian symbolism he would give him
everything he would even support the
publication of the bestiary of christ
even though genoa at that time was a
muslim he would give everything to
shabonu because he thought that was an
extraordinary project
in fact he was asking shabono for
his opinion on christian symbolism
and shabono would ask geno for
other
traditions
interpretation because one symbol can be
interpreted many ways depending on the
context so it was an interesting
collaboration of respect however they
would keep their ground uh
separate yeah separate because
charbonneau even though you know talking
about geno even though he is clearly
catholic and orthodox he's also not
afraid to point to the places where
these similar structures appear in other
cultures he's not also kind of a
correct he's not close-minded and
focused only on his thing but really
sees through the christian lands even
some symbolism coming from ancient pagan
cultures or from other cultures as well
yeah and i think that came from his
archaeology background but also from
genome
i have actually
we'll talk about this later but i have
you know all these archives that shabano
left behind and there is hundreds of
notes of when he met with genome and
they talked about this subject or
another it was fascinating
this is the indiana jones now part of
the story so tell us what happened to
his work and and also your part in
rediscovering it yeah so you asked me
earlier and i never answered how i found
out about shabunu so i was reading
genome and i was talking to some friends
of mine who say hey you should buy the
best theory of christ so that was
mid-90s
and
so i did
i purchased the bestiary of christ and
found it fascinating i read it from
beginning to and even though it looks
like kind of a dictionary almost every
every
uh animal is
is listed with a symbol and based on
but i read it as a whole and i came out
of this book with a very strange feeling
and i don't know how the english version
is it's been shortened yeah that's a
product yeah
there's a project of doing a new version
i'll be involved as well we're going to
translate the whole thing
but after i finished reading the book i
was
i had a kind of a
an experience of
suddenly i was looking outside and i
loved being in the woods and all that
and everything
suddenly i realized everything
could symbolize christ
the the the grant not just the man but
the
the god of nature yeah with the nature
basically that's right so we started
with the animals and it just blew my
mind and i wanted to know more so that's
when i started doing some of my own
research i had some access to geno's
letters that uh an italian
scholar pierre luigi socatelli had
published he published a few books
so i contacted this gentleman
and
we became friends and um
and that's how i learned through him and
and
uh
that
shabono had planned to write other books
the best year was one of several he was
going to write another book about the
symbolism of the plants and vegetable
vegetables
for uh that represent christ in any way
possible
and then third book about uh
minerals
but that's not it what i found out
through the archives he was going to
write books about other items there were
anything liturgic
objects uh
planets and stars it was anything that
could exist
which represent christ and that's kind
of an interesting approach
to uh
instead of hypothetism when you cannot
express
god god without talking negatively about
him he took another approach with the
infinity of god is expressed to the
infinity of all the manifestation
everything on earth and the universe i
thought it was fascinating i've never
seen that before and that's that's been
my passion so i was wondering and that's
where it was interesting what happened
to those archives
so i was actually walking at that time
it was
early 2010
with uh the genome happily i was
uh gathering all the writing of genome
and all these letters because i was i
was just curious
and in the process they shared with me
some letters they had of shabu no lasse
they were kept in cairo in egypt where
genome finished his life
and they shared those letters with me so
i could i had them in my hand
and i was reading the letters and i
realized there was that book the
vulnerability of christ
that he finished
just before his death he was very old he
was in late 70s he was complaining to
gain on that his eyes didn't work very
well
the publishing company had lost a lot of
his engravings he had to redo 60 or 70
of those it was it was fascinating and
he was telling the whole
table of content of the book
and it was very interesting because what
i found out is that that book had been
stolen after his death we don't know the
condition we don't know anything but
somebody came to the
people who owned all the archives of
shabono and he borrowed the manuscript
saying he was going to publish it and he
was never found again wow
yeah
so
what i did
i tracked those archives i i contacted
the
family so they shared a lot of things
with me but they didn't have those
outcasts
and
this brings us to a very mysterious and
kind of uh
indiana jones story is that
i don't know if you know that but
there is somebody who helped chabono
with the symbolism of the middle age
middle a medieval symbolism of the
sacred heart and all these
symbols in the bestiary
one of charbonneau's mentor
he was a
a priest nearby named uh
theophil
i may have a picture of him i'll share
that with you uh
for the audience
and this gentleman was very old um
shabano was helping him just like he was
very uh helping him with his with his
day-to-day
uh
kind of he he couldn't write so he would
write for him he was very old
and that gentleman
theophil babo
shared with shabonu that he was part of
a
an organization of christians
called
and that was kind of an organization of
a few people i'm not going to say a
secret organization because that's
really not fair but kind of an
organization of
a few people
who
who were carrying archives from the
middle age it was very strange and it's
it's it and they shared their
information with shabono so he could
write about it because the content
wasn't in line with what chabun was
studying the symbolism of animals the
symbolism of the the sacred hearts
so they gaven they this old man gave him
their archives to study
and he they also had
carried through the middle age some kind
of a
night knighthood
uh ritual
it was called the chevalier du parkly
the the the knights of the holy spirit
if you want
just some kind of a
group of people like that would protect
that knowledge
and they made charbonneau
he transmitted to shabono the
basically that the right to make new
nights that's why he was included he was
brought into this yes
yes
so after his death
he
left all his archives to the few of
those knights that still lived at the
time and they were by the way friends of
renegade so it was a small group
their goal and i found out in the letter
was to use the archives to finish the
work of shambanu they're gonna finish
the book about the
the the plants the book about the
minerals
and uh but they they didn't uh the the
group died everybody uh
it didn't survive it just just invisible
yeah that's what i hear
so those archives were still in the
position of
the last of those nights
i think is
a friend of the last of the night after
he died in 1999 uh
sold those archives to
publishers in italy
it's just strange
interestingly the owner of those
archives was the one who published
the bestiary of christ in
um
in the 80s or 70s in the french version
there was a facsimile his name was
laszlo tops he was the director of the
arcade editions
and um
he's the one i've met
and um first he showed them to me
um so i could consult and he wanted he
was supporting me he wanted me to help
reconstitute the books because he was 80
years old when i met him he passed he
passed away a few weeks ago
yeah and he um
and uh in the end i negotiated hey can i
can i own them can i buy them from you
so we agreed on the price but i could
not afford that price because first
my wife didn't want me to spend my money
on that garbage
and i respected that so what i did is i
said well what if i did a crowdfunding
project okay where i asked all the
traditionalists around the world to uh
hold on i think my dog wants to come
join us
to to see if they wanted to help and
they did and we did that 2016 i started
the
crowd crowdfunding project
and in
two weeks i had the money two weeks
so i i i
bought the archives it was sent to me
and now i have uh
i mean hundreds of folders and i'm going
to share that with you it's really i'm
going to show you a little bit
so for example this one is about
the byzantine lazy
yeah
yeah intimacy presents so it has these
notes
so it's just so it's made of so it's
interesting because we're talking about
the 1930s 1940s so this is shipping
paper it was recycling
paper that was used
uh yeah originally that symbol was for
the mountain okay buddy the content
became um yeah so we have something
yeah yeah
and it's at the back of letters so you
can see uh i may have some renegade on
this 100 of them then he he talks about
the contents and so it's been plenty of
notes
so it's all organized by symbol
and then there is
yeah like he would recycle some some of
his own writings and um there's some
beautiful things so it's foreign artists
and and
for an artist it is an extraordinary
mind of information and inspiration
so what i've decided to do and that's
important you may not know that
in exchange for the forgetting the funds
my goal is to share that with everybody
so for the past three years i have
scanned every single of those archives
and they are now available there's about
40 000 notes
for everyone i have a website called
uh i'll i'll give you the link achieve
shabonolase.org
and you can have access to everything
so that's
my role is to share that's really what
it is
it's amazing
so but there's a lot of
so you've been able to scan the entire
archives and yeah these are all his
engravings all the drawings are his yes
all of them
and then i even have some uh
some
some things i'm going to show you so
it's beautiful like he did some
engravings of the
holy land yeah
nice
yeah this is the
this is called the rosa mystica 1923
yeah some of the these are more stylized
very beautiful yes they are they are and
then he has it's funny he was keeping
track of all his engravings he's done
thousands
in sheets that you would just print them
so you would remember what you had
uh-huh
right right yeah this is one of the
underground he was exploring when he was
uh these 19 yeah it's caves so there's
some of that there's some uh all kind of
uh
all kind of stuff
it's it's just incredible it's just
incredible and there's a museum in
france shabo no lasse it's in luda
they have inherited all well
these archives went to the knights of
the paraklet
everything he found archaeologically
wise is at a museum in in luda so i
contacted them and we became really
close they gave me access to they kept
they still have the engravings the
pieces of wood wow that he engraved with
a knife he was done with a knife
and um it's it's uh
it's fascinating so now the books or the
vulnerary
were you able to recover the manuscript
or did you reconstruct it good question
i'm still not so
so that's going back to the indiana
jones so
when i when i saw in the letters he sent
again on the table of content and i
realized i had a lot of
because even for the best theory a lot
of
the chapters were published separately
in the periodical over 10 years he had
he modified them a little later but he
done the same with the
the content of vulnerary okay and and so
i was i started collecting everything he
published because i found some stuff
from the 1910s some 1936.
it was all over but because i had the
table of content i knew what to look for
so i had to reconstitute some of it
and i had to and i was able to reuse
some of what he published but my
original goal was i'm going to publish a
reconstituted
vulnerary
it doesn't matter if it's accurate i
want the person who stole it to come out
and say hey this is not right i have the
manuscript
it never happened never happened
no never happened i don't know where it
is
huh
well it's a strange world too it's a
it's a it's a world of secrets so
sometimes there are people involved in
these circles that uh that find power
and secrecy and so i agree i agree
i agree and one of those is
yeah it's being part of a group you
i do not know what happened with that
manuscript obviously the person who took
it is probably not alive anymore this
was another generation
uh but i i have hints i mean i have a
name um the goal is to
my quest is not over
that's astounding that's really amazing
wow this is it's such a it's such a
great story also because you know i also
had my you know my interest in shabano
uh of course early on when i became
interested in symbolism you know because
he was far more christian and far more
and i was that that was the direction
that i was taking and so obviously the
bestiary was an important part of my
kind of my formation and and
even just the possibility of thinking
about medieval symbolism and
and uh i mean western's western medieval
imagery is often more emblematic and so
it's it's even more it's more easily
interpreted in the way that you know
would interpret symbolism almost in a
geometric way and so i can really see i
could really see how charbonneau and him
would would come together quite quite
well in terms of uh
bringing out christian symbolism so this
is so it's wonderful to see these books
coming out and and also there are future
projects that you're putting together
i'm working on reconstituting the the
lapidary of christ lapidary from stones
and i've started
so it's it's
i am amazed at what he gathered i'm
putting this together in french now of
course he'll be translated in english
after that because french is my original
language it's also the all these notes
are in french but
um right now just studying
just the basic rock
um for example the rock
symbolizes something that is
indestructible right
i even go even further think about the
diamond
diamond stone i'm writing an article
about this i'll love to share it with
you when it's published
the diamond
um
i don't know if you knew that but
nobody knew how to cut a diamond until
the
15th century when
uh with technologies people were able to
use diamonds to cut diamonds but back in
the early
ages
a diamond was found in the rough and it
was indestructible
they could not
break it the hammer would bounce off it
and and you couldn't do anything and
it's when it comes naturally that's the
form of an octagon yeah kind of a
diamond shape you know diamond that's
why
but when you look at the symbolism
uh and i just finished
studying this charbonneau identified
that because
the diamond stone is indestructible
it symbolizes
the
the indivisibility
god cannot be
divided
in fact i would say even further
the
god is without dimensions therefore you
cannot cut it you cannot divide it you
cannot measure it but that's what the
diamond was symbolizing
and um and and what's interesting is
that
the diamond can only be
cut by itself
and
if there were some old symbolism where
the diamond was associated to jesus
christ
because
the symbol
you know when he was on the cross he let
that happen to him
so
when you look at the uh old testament
when moses
uses staff to hate a rock and water
comes out of it to to
to
help the the jews this is actually a
configuration of christ on the cross
where he he died to to redeem the world
well what's interesting is you can see
that a lot with the symbolism of the
rock in the old testament
uh mercies goes to the top of a mountain
to go see god uh in the old legends
the diamond could only be found
in the eastern mountain at the very top
okay and you put it on it makes sense
yeah in terms of the symbolism makes
sense like it's a heavenly stone almost
yeah that's right and and the last thing
is you know uh there's that story where
uh uh
the the builders they reject that stone
that look like nothing and that becomes
the stone that you use the capstone
to finish a church or a vault or
whatever so the capstone symbol end up
symbolizing christ because he was
rejected by anyone but he was the most
precious stone of all where everything
holds because of him so
we found all manuscript medieval
manuscripts or the shape of a diamond
was put at the top of a vault the same
way amazing yeah that's just one yeah
it's an amazing joining of all the
symbolism together because i remember
that
one of the insights that i got from
guinea which is that
the idea of the rejecting stone becomes
the cornerstone that's how we used to
understand it but you know really
brought about the idea that no it's the
it's the capstone or the
arch you know it's the idea of this last
stone that you put in which holds it
together and i thought that's it and
since then like there's no i could never
interpret it differently it just it
makes so much sense but the idea of
having this diamond you know this image
of the diamond at the top in in the in
the vault is wonderful in terms of
indivisibility and this heavenly stone
that comes down that's great stuff
yeah i'll send that to you that way you
can show your audience i definitely
definitely will so that's a very
exciting project so you've got several
exciting projects to uh
to uh to to still work on yeah it's
probably a lifetime and i probably won't
finish it and i'll pass it on to
somebody else and that's
seems like that's what happened to me
there was a generation who tried they
started i have a lot of notes and all
that from others passed it on to me i
was able to publish the vulnerary
and i'll try to continue and pass it on
to others
yeah it's wonderful and and you haven't
had any you haven't had much resistance
which is great like the the
or maybe you have you didn't just didn't
tell us um
well i'm
i'm not very
public you know i i don't
i mean
when i talk to christians in general
that friends of mine who don't
understand symbolism they think it's
paganism they think it's
yeah all kind of stuff but
yeah so i don't talk about this
only with people who can understand
now in private i have i'm walking right
now with a small group in argentina
who
are
christians they love symbolism and they
are translating the venere right now so
i'm helping them i'm sharing those
archives with them and we're going to
publish that one probably at the end of
the year the spanish version of the
veneer that's wonderful yeah i found
that in
south america there's some interesting
uh
in brazil as well there's a interesting
resurgence of symbolic thinking which is
which is definitely worth
in being invested in yeah that's really
amazing um so and so you also i may be
my last question because you mentioned
that you were taught you were working
with the guinea family as well in terms
of of collating some of the letters is
that a project you're still involved
with
so i did it for them um
no i'm not involved anymore there was a
few years ago uh they had a kind of a
they called a foundation where they
would uh
uh attempt to
get basically they wanted to publish all
the work of geno
revised but
the
this project has stopped uh geno's work
is going to be in the public domain next
year
january 2022
and i think at that time it's gonna be
completely uh free-for-all basically
everybody's gonna publish whatever they
want unfortunately but uh i had access
to all those letters
of course there's a lot of
confidentiality you know it's it's it's
for them yeah but i i yeah i
had access to a lot of letters
and by the way i have a website again uh
where i actually put all the genomes
work in french including the
correspondence all the letters
for all to access and this website has
really means is 10 years old now
it has thousands of visitors every day
and i believe it helps bring genomes
work to
the masses if you want in some ways uh
but um
really
my
i mean i live in the united states i've
been here for 20 years
my
goal was to try to bring
uh some of genome but mostly charbonneau
lassies work to
the anglo-saxon or the english-speaking
world and that's i i was very impressed
when uh
i mean angelico quest
i don't know if you knew that when i
tried to get my crowdfunding going on i
sent a few emails in the united states a
few people i knew
uh one
person who helped me was james cutsinger
have you heard of james yeah i had
friends i was friends with james
cutsinger i made i made some even some
pieces for the end of his life oh wow
yeah yeah
so he helped me very early on uh early
in the 2000s when i was early i didn't
even know about shabo no and all that
but i was kind of guided towards the
symbolism of the hearts yeah which is
the center which is everything is one of
those who helped me and when i uh
contacted him to say hey i'm doing a
crowdfunding crowdfunding he sent it to
a few other people there's very few in
the united states in north america you
probably know them all but one of them
was jean champu john shampoo
who
[Music]
could not
why he offered instead of the
crowdfunding to give me money he said
what if i translate the vulnerary in
english for you
and that's what he did it took him years
and and then he contacted angelico press
we worked together we did another
crowdfunding so we could pay for this
but it went really well so it is
definitely a walk of passion we don't do
that for the money nobody buys this book
you know it will never
it won't it would be a better seller but
it no no no we'll have uh it will have
an impact uh i think so everybody you
need to you need to get it i'm still
working through it it's a it's a massive
book it's heavily documented it has
it has hundreds i think like at least a
hundred images of all the different
engravings that shabanola say uh has
done so it's really a wonderful book and
it's really like i said
it's really in terms of my work a
precursor someone who laid the
foundation for symbolic thinking in the
christian world and so we're we're very
grateful
for him and go to very grateful for the
work you're doing and looking forward to
seeing it uh continue to flower so
thanks yeah no problem man uh
i will send you the link to the archives
and and um never hesitate if you want me
to look for something in the archives
i'll i'll send them to you i was the
other day you walked on that uh san
christopher
with a dog head located man yeah and i
found out in these archives as well so i
thought it was cool i remember seeing
that image in the early bestiary edition
like the french edition that that was
actually probably the first time i ever
saw that image was in charbonneau's
early uh like the french edition the
facsimile one that was like just it was
it was massive that book
yeah it was it was that's awesome yeah
so
so it's great and yeah for now like i
think that
uh yeah it's an opening for people to
look into medieval symbolism and like i
said for everybody who's interested in
symbolism you know he was our he's our
ancestor in uh in a spiritual way so so
look into the vulnerary and the bestiary
looking forward to the full publication
of the book and all the future projects
so thanks a lot now you're welcome
thanks for having me